Every piece of every product that we use in our day-to-day lives...
...was created by someone.
But even the greatest, most inspired maker can't imagine everything,...
...can't anticipate every need.
That's why it's so important for us to work in diverse teams of individuals...
...who bring their own distinct world view to their work,...
...their needs and preferences, their opinions and experiences,...
...their knowledge and expertise.
This diversity of perspectives is the recipe for great products.
Envision a place where the folks who make the things that power our lives...
...are a true reflection of our community and our world.
Imagine what awesome things they could build to better serve us all.